denis demonpion éditorialistes bonsoir
denis demonpion merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france à voir selon
vous ces craintes rapportées par nos
confrères du monde est ce qu elles sont
crédibles elles sont un petit peu
grotesque en réalité parce que pour deux
raisons c'est que déjà on est à un an et
demi au moins de la présidentielle donc
il est encore bien trop tôt pour comment
dirais-je spéculer sur qui sera pas
candidat bon pour le moment il ya une
candidate déclarée c'est marine le pen
qui je crois il ya déjà deux trois mois
a clairement dit qu'elle serait tourné
là qu'elle porterait les couleurs du
rassemblement national ce qui n'était
pas vraiment une surprise en soi et
maintenant que le chef de l'état sa muse
et surtout que les journaux rapportent
de manière aussi officiel ces
conversations privées avec jean-marie
bigeard eric zemmour etc etc
le proxy de raout bon sa rencontre
d'ailleurs sa visite chez procédera août
avait été un petit peu mise en scène il
ya le plus grave y'a plusieurs genres
j'allais dire après deux mois de comics
l'économie est très mal en point dans ce
pays d'ailleurs il n'est pas encore
reparti l'endettement de la france va
être colossal les déficits également le
chômage n'en parlons pas et je pense que
le président la république serait plus
comment dirais-je une idée là même de
traiter ces questions plutôt que de
passer son temps au téléphone
justement quel est l'intérêt pour le
président de la république de
communiquer sur ses appels à sept
personnages parfois controversés enfin
en l'occurrence et jean marie bigard qui
lie à communiquer lui sur le fait que le
président l'avait appelé mais il
n'empêche ça se sait il ya bien un
intérêt qu à emmanuel macron à cela non
écoutez c'est un peu les qu'une de la
politique si je se dire car
bon vous l'avez 10 gens râlent bigeard a
annoncé sur une radio que l'on le
président de la république l'avait
appelé mais si c'est pour comment
dirais-je prévenir d'éventuelles
candidatures parce que c'est vrai que le
nom d'eric zemmour était revenue de
manière un peu plus sérieuse après sa
prestation devant un aréopage de membres
du rassemblement national et des droites
assez dur là il était apparu comme
quelqu'un susceptible d'être un candidat
sérieux
on n'en est pas là parce que c'est pas
la première fois dans les élections
présidentielles et même des mois avant
que il ya comme ça des chevau légers
dans ton donne des noms il ya eu dans le
passé vous avez deux exemples marquants
ça a été le premier le comédien yves
montand savait à l'époque qui était un
comédien extrêmement populaire et
d'ailleurs des gens de gauche avaient
essayé de trouver une troisième voie à
gauche en promouvant sa candidature
malheureusement il ya eu des émissions
de télé c'est autour de lui et puis ça
n'a jamais abouti y est le candidat le
plus sérieux en réalité ça a été coluche
vous avez dans les alicaments ritz lui
était quand même crédité dans les
sondages alors il avait une vraie
popularité
contrairement à 10 grammes c'est quand
même un épiphénomène j'allais dire eric
zemmour même chose
jean marie billa n'en parlons pas on
voit mal ces trois hommes prétendre
sérieusement à la présidentielle
maintenant c'est leur droit
c'est pas la première fois qu'ils
auraient des candidats un peu j'allais
dire fantaisistes et il y en a eu
d'ailleurs à la présidentielle de 1965
des candidats qui font 1% il ya toujours
d'ailleurs vous savez françois
asselineau qui a quelques ennuis
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui avec certains
éléments de son parti qui régulièrement
se remet en selle pour essayer de faire
passer ses idées
mention pardon de vous couper mais enfin
bon sous-estimer un petit peu cette voie
là se pendent de l'opinion publique qui
effectivement est peut-être vous
l'erreur on appelle ça comme ça on petit
système ça a été le cas notamment aussi
en italie ou beppe grillo se souvient un
humoriste a fini par être élu vous n'y
croyez pas du tout c'est quelque chose
pour nous en finissions crédible
mouvement d'un gilet jaune très fort en
france notamment
il peut regarder movement gilet jaune on
a vu ce que ça va donner quand ils se
sont présentés aux élections municipales
et européennes qui n'ont pratiquement
pas fait de voir non l'assaut des
personnalités individuelles
ça n'a rien à voir avec le la manière
dont emmanuel macron lui même qui
n'était pas d'ailleurs hors système
puisque il avait fait quand même ces
armes à la fois sous nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande est bien il avait
constitué un parti il une organisation
autour de lui qui est absolument
indispensable pour pouvoir percer dans
une élection comme ça que je sache
aujourd'hui didier raoult qui est sans
doute un professeur émérite remarquer
etc
il n'a pas cette infrastructure derrière
lui pas plus d'ailleurs qu'eric zemmour
et encore moins genre exigea jean marie
bigard pousse un coup de gueule pour
qu'en effet on ouvre lévi strauss est
peut-être très populaire mais je ne sais
pas combien de temps cette popularité
comment tirage s'imprégnera dans le
paysage politique et tout sera
véritablement l'opinion publique je
pense que l'opinion attend des gens qui
répondent à leurs problèmes apporte des
solutions aux questions qu'ils se posent
et je dirais un peu de sérieux
denis demonpion d'avoir été avec noé